was im augenblick die größte rolle
spielt ist die innenpolitik aber auch
die innenpolitik wird von außen
betrachtet nämlich vom europäischen und
außereuropäischen ausland und das
schaute man auf deutschland und es gab
ein schreckgespenst das wurde immer
wieder erwähnt das war rot grün rot dazu
wird es sicherlich nicht kommen wir
haben mal gefragt wie sehen die
korrespondenten die stimmung in den
ländern bei dieser wahl
es gibt noch keine offizielle reaktion
der us-regierung aber sie rechnete schon
vor der wahl mit einer schwächung der
deutschen führungsrolle in europa weil
eine dreier-koalition eine gemeinsame
außenpolitische linie erschwert immerhin
sieht joe biden eine
regierungsbeteiligung der grünen als
zeichen dafür dass deutschland sich in
einigen fragen bewegen könnte die dem
weißen haus besonders am herzen liegen
der kampf gegen den klimawandel und eine
deutlich härtere linie gegenüber
autoritären systemen wie russland und
china so sehr die usa angela merkel als
verlässliche berechenbare partnerin in
europa schätzen so sehr sehen sie die
bundeskanzlerin bei diesen themen auf
der bremse die aus sicht der beiden
administration über erfolg oder
misserfolg der liberalen demokratien in
ihrer auseinandersetzung mit dem
autoritär ismus entscheiden man hat hier
erwartungsvoll notiert dass seine
mögliche außenministerin und vize
kanzlerin annalena baerbock wohl
amerikas vorbehalte gegenüber der nord
stream-pipeline teilen im umgang mit
china die samthandschuhe ablegen und
beim klima ähnlich wie beiden eine große
umwälzung vorantreiben würde die
us-regierung hätte sich sicher gewünscht
dass beim g 20 gipfel in rom ende
oktober und beim klimagipfel in glasgow
anfang november schon klarer wäre wohin
deutschland steuert aber wenn die
koalitionsbildung länger dauert hofft
die beiden administrationen trotzdem
dass angela merkel bei wichtigen
vorhaben an der seite der usa stehen
wird auch hier in russland hat man die
bundestagswahl mit großer aufmerksamkeit
verfolgt wobei aus russischer sicht ist
nicht allzu wichtig ob jetzt die union
oder die spd vorne liegen sowohl olaf
scholz als auch an laschet haben in
puncto russland dann doch ähnliche
positionen vertreten beide unterstützen
die umstrittene gaspipeline nord stream
2 beide sehen sie als ein
wirtschaftliches projekt für den kreml
ist das durchaus auch ein politisches
projekt und deswegen hat man hier sehr
genau verfolgt was die grünen für
positionen vertreten haben die haben
sich ja deutlich gegen die gas pipeline
ausgesprochen mehr druck auf russland
gefordert und eine menschenrechts
orientierte außenpolitik gefordert
hätten es die grünen ins kanzleramt
geschafft dann wäre es für russland
sicherlich deutlich ungemütlicher
geworden so mit olaf scholz oder falls
es doch noch armin laschet wird kann man
sich in russland wohl auf ein weiter so
in den beziehungen einstellen einzig an
die neuen namen wird man sich gewöhnen
müssen denn außer angela merkel gibt es
wenige deutsche politiker die in
russland wirklich bekannt sind china
schaut skeptisch auf die neue
bundesregierung aus chinesischer sicht
besteht zu befürchten dass
menschenrechtsfragen wichtiger werden
als wirtschaftliche fragen und dass
dadurch eine schieflage entsteht in
china wird angela merkel fast hymnisch
in den medien gefeiert sie gilt als
vermittlerin sie gilt als brückenbauerin
und sie steht für eine politik die da
heißt wandel durch handel
doch diese politik scheint nun vorbei zu
sein alle deutschen parteien sind sich
einig dass die chinapolitik härter
werden soll man steht kritisch china
gegenüber und das in sehr vielen
bereichen den menschenrechtsfragen in
wirtschaftspolitischen fragen auch
geostrategisch das heißt der neue
bundeskanzler
er steht auch vor einem dilemma es
zerrissen zwischen den beiden
großmächten usa und china die usa sind
wichtig für deutschland aus
sicherheitspolitischen gründen und china
ist wichtig für deutschland auch aus
wirtschaftspolitischen gründen
die frage ist jetzt ob ein neuer
bundeskanzler
dieses dilemma lösen kann hier in
brüssel ist man noch sehr zurückhaltend
mit der bewertung des deutschen
wahlergebnisses lediglich spanien und
schweden haben sich bisher geäußert und
olaf scholz zum wahlsieg gratuliert das
ist aber auch nicht verwunderlich denn
bei der regierung gehören auch dem
sozialdemokratischen oder
sozialistischen lager in dem parteien
familien an ansonsten guckt man sehr
genau darauf welche regierungen jetzt
gebildet wird und vor allen dingen
welche rolle die kleineren
koalitionspartner spielen die
niederlande beispielsweise setzen
wahrscheinlich darauf dass die fdp eine
starke rolle bekommt am besten im
finanzministerium denn die niederlande
dringen schon lange darauf dass
möglichst der eu-haushalt klein gehalten
wird dass die fiskalregeln eingehalten
werden und dass man nicht zu viele
schulden macht das hofft man dass das
eine fdp in der bundesregierung stärker
durchsetzen würde umgekehrt frankreich
auch wenn das land das natürlich nicht
direkt sagt setzt wahrscheinlich auf
eine starke rolle der grünen einfach
weil man sich da mehrere formen schwung
in der eu erhofft insgesamt gibt es eine
sorge davor dass die regierungsbildung
in deutschland jetzt sehr lange dauern
könnte denn hier liegen wirklich
schwierige fragen auf dem tisch die
relativ schnell eigentlich beantwortet
werden sollen zum beispiel wer denn
welche lasten beim klimaschutz tragen
muss es ist unvorstellbar dass solche
grundsätzlichen entscheidung getroffen
werden ohne eine wirklich
funktionierende neue regierung also
diese sorge gibt es insgesamt lernt die
eu über deutschland dass das land was
immer stabil war und was letztlich von
cdu oder spd klar regiert wurde jetzt
eben die kleineren parteien entdeckt
also vom hort der stabilität immer
manchmal auch ein bisschen langweilig zu
einem land wo gilt anything goes
wer auch immer der neue deutsche kanzler
werden wird scholz oder laschet der
elysée palast ließ durchblicken dass mit
beiden der deutsch französische motor
weiter rund laufen wird beide gelten als
makro kompatibel beide kennt man beide
hatten sich bereits vor der wahl beim
französischen präsidenten vorgestellt
man weiß um die gemeinsamkeiten und um
die differenzen etwas zurückhaltender
blickt man auf die koalitionspartner die
grünen zu grünen die liberalen zu
liberal überhaupt vernehmen die
franzosen mit großem erstaunen dass
gleich drei parteien sich zu einem
regierungsbündnis zusammenraufen müssen
so etwas wäre in frankreich undenkbar
und so blickt man interessiert aber auch
ein bisschen irritiert auf diesen
nachbarn und diesen partner die jetzt
erst zum die rungen und
koalitionsverhandlungen führen muss
bevor er kann da feststeht und das ist
genau das was präsident makro besonders
umtreibt die frage nämlich wie lange
dauern diese koalitionsverhandlungen und
welchen einfluss nehmen die
koalitionspartner die grünen und die
liberalen auf die politik januar wird
der termin sein an dem frankreich die
die eu-ratspräsidentschaft übernehmen
wird und mit einem großen und
ambitionierten programm besonders was
die verteidigung die europäische
verteidigung anbelangt und da braucht
frankreich einen starken deutschen
partner an seiner seite und keinen der
ausschließlich mit sich selbst
beschäftigt ist in polen schaut man sehr
genau auf das wahlergebnis in
deutschland und die zukunft es war eines
der zentralen themen in den nachrichten
seit gestern abend aber ob es am ende
einen kanzler olaf scholz oder armin
laschet geben wird ist aus polnischer
sicht nicht so entscheidend denn in
beiden fällen geht man davon aus dass es
für die deutsch polnischen beziehungen
vor allem eins bedeutet kontinuität und
das ist vor allem für die
wirtschaftsbeziehungen wichtig denn
diesen traditionell sehr eng angela
merkel hat in ihrer 16 jährigen amtszeit
vor allem für eins gesorgt
berechenbarkeit in diesen beziehungen
auch bei einigen unstimmigkeiten wie zum
beispiel dem thema rechtsstaatlichkeit
jetzt ist abzuwarten wie sich die
politik in der zukunft entwickelt
außenpolitik hat ja im deutschen
wahlkampf keine große rolle gespielt
aber eine sorge geht schon um denn wenn
die grünen an der regierung beteiligt
werden geht man davon aus dass das thema
klimapolitik auch in polen deutlich
angesprochen wird hier wird ja immer
noch viel strom aus kohle gewonnen auch
bei den minderheitenrechten wenn es um
lgp die cue geht rechnet man damit dass
wenn die grünen an der regierung
beteiligt sind dann auch ein stärkerer
wind in richtung polen wählt aber jetzt
heißt es aus polnischer sicht erst mal
abwarten wie sich die regierung dort in
der zukunft aufstellt welche koalitionen
es gibt und bis dahin setzt man im guten
sinne auf kontinuität
deutschland wählt die aufregung ist groß
es geht um sehr viel für das vereinigte
königreich das war 2017 so als man
mitten im rexit prozess stecken vier
jahre später ist deutschland weiterhin
ein wichtiger verbündeter aber
großbritannien hat sich eben von europa
abgewendet und werden nun den regierungs
vorsitz in der größten volkswirtschaft
der eu innehat ist hier nicht mehr so
relevant dazu kommt dass ihre
komplizierte wahlsystem aus britischer
sicht dass man jetzt wochen und
monatelang eigentlich gar nicht weiß wer
gewonnen hat wer den neuen
regierungschef dann stellt das ist für
die briten echt unverständlich wenn hier
gewählt wird nach dem mehrheitswahlrecht
dann weiß man am morgen danach wer
gewinnt wer regiert und der der regiert
kann durchregieren mit einer satten
mehrheit und betrachtet man die
außenpolitischen portfolios der beiden
potenziellen kanzler scholz und laschet
da gibt es einfach wenig unterschied aus
britischer sicht und insofern dürfte das
auch dann keinen großen unterschied
machen